then Shapiro and the liberal Lions Den
this week with Bill Maher the editor in
chief of daily wire.com joins me now now
I think the only reason you really
stumped him there Ben was because he was
high he smokes before the show we're
hearing that might have accounted for
him not being able to respond to that
quickly but I want to talk to you about
the top three SCOTUS picks that
president Trump's ruminating about tell
me what your assessment is of Brett
Kavanaugh who seems to be the early
establishment insider frontrunner so I'm
a little bit dicey on Brett Kavanaugh
and and the reason is not just because
he's sort of the bush inside her pick
he's obviously very close with the bush
team he was one of the the forces behind
the selection of John Roberts but there
are two specific cases in which Brett
Cavanaugh has has I think done less than
then originalist would like so in one
particular case he denied jurisdiction
on Obamacare because he said that
Obamacare was actually a tax it was the
first time anybody had made the argument
that Obamacare was a tax rather than
fine and as you'll recall that was the
logic that ended up being used by Chief
Justice Roberts in determining that
Obama care was in fact legal under the
Constitution so the original logic for
that came from a Cavanaugh dissent in a
case called 7 very concerning to a lot
of people go ahead yeah there's another
case called priests for life in which
Cavanaugh suggested that the government
had a compelling government interest in
providing contraceptive care via
insurance to folks and there are a lot
of critics who suggest that that that
case is a little bit of evidence that he
takes too seriously the government
stated interests in a particular leftist
social issues but he is considered a
strong conservative choice The Wall
Street Journal editorial page endorsed
him match slap American Conservative
Union has also endorsed him it wouldn't
be a bad pick you're saying we could do
better and one of the people I've heard
you discusses Amy Barrett who I think
now a lot of the social conservatives
and the constitutional conservatives are
really getting behind at the last minute
she seemed to be surging what are you
hearing about her that's no the the
truth is that Coney Barrett's actual
judicial resume is very short because
she's only been on a federal circuit
court for about a year ever since she
those really contentious hearings with
Democrats where they accuse her having
the doctrine live loudly within her and
Catholicism was going to rule the day
and all this kind of nonsense so what we
know about her is that she's written a
lot in terms of academic writing a lot
of for academic writing has centered on
originalism and textualism she's a big
supporter of the doctrines and
philosophies of Justice Scalia
she's obviously personally very pro-life
and and so she twerked against Scalia
and she's only 46 years old so that
would be a very very long time on the
bench if she ever was appointed and
Catholic person like you said an
originalist really interprets the
Constitution as it was written and now
we're hearing about Raymond Catholic now
Raymond Catholics the third person he
was the runner-up to Gorsuch and now
he's making a late surge to he clerked
for kennedy university of michigan guy
what do you know about him mr. Keval is
a resume is quite good his decisions are
very strong they're well worded he tends
to write strong opinions I would say the
Brett Kavanaugh his opinions are very
politically inclined in the sense that
he's attempting to create sort of
cohesion on the court kept his opinions
are a lot more kind of punch him in the
nose opinions he has a very strong
record on the second amendment in
particular he also has a very strong
record with regard to something called
Chevron deference which is the idea that
when an administrative agency makes a
judgment that that can still be Chevron
deference suggested shouldn't be
overruled by the judiciary he says the
judiciary is a separate branch and the
judiciary should overrule that the
judiciary has to overrule which I think
is correct okay I think Hethel edges is
a strong candidate okay so if you were
to rank the most conservative to the
least conservative or the person that
you would like to see on the bench the
most you probably would choose Barrett
number one I'm hearing may be Catholic
to Cavanaugh three do I have that right
that's that's right okay but all all
solid picks to replace Justice Kennedy
who was the swing justice all right now
right although I wouldn't say that the
best shot that one of them ends up being
Roberts is probably Cavanaugh yeah
Roberts not not the best but still
really not that bad and this new memo
we're seeing from Peters truck our old
friend at the FBI something that we've
just uncovered you
I don't know why this didn't come up in
the IG report or any of the other
requests to turn over these memos and
text messages there was something that
said hurry the F up to pressure to probe
the Trump campaign and this was in the
fall 2016 so he's talking about hurrying
this thing up
obviously politically motivated and
electorally motivated what is your
thinking behind that it's just more and
more nonsense or what I'd say it's not a
shock at all I mean Michael Horowitz and
that IG report suggested that Peter
struck was making decisions to privilege
the the timing of the Trump
investigation above the Hillary
investigation in fact one of the reasons
they say that the Hillary investigation
the reopening of the Hillary email
investigation was delayed until late
October is because struck wanted to
place focus on the Trump investigation
because he wanted to get it done before
the actual election took place truck is
a political actor there's no question
about this and even Horowitz essentially
suggested as much in that much-maligned
IG report so it looks you know if the if
the FBI was not out to get President
Trump it certainly looks like Peter
struck was right and he was too much of
a political hack to be on the Muller
team I don't see why that reasoning
wouldn't you know disallow him from
being on the Comey team so either way
he's poisoned it it's just a matter of
how far they're gonna take that now the
DNC chairman Perez he was asked about
this woman out of the Bronx Acacio
Cortes who was an abolish ice activist
an avowed socialist and here is what the
chairman of the DNC said about an avowed
socialist listen I have three kids to
whom our daughters one just graduated
college one is in college and they were
both texting me about their excitement
over Alexandria because she really she
represents the future of our party so
socialism is the future of the
Democratic Party then I don't think the
Democratic Party has a future because
that's not going you know I think the
Democratic Party obviously has moved
radically left in terms of identity
politics and intersectionality and
Acacio Cortez represents sort of the
merger of the intersectional wing of the
Democratic Party with the Bernie Sanders
socialist wing of the Democratic
party and while it's easy to dismiss the
socialism of that I'm a chronic party
the truth is that we live in a country
that tends to swing back and forth
between the parties it's it's not good
for the country that the Democratic
Party has moved so far to the left that
they're now flanking some European
left-wing parties because you have to
imagine at some point these jokers could
be back in power well I mean remember
what happened with Barack Obama he took
the country way far left and you saw a
huge rebellion with the Tea Party they
destroyed the Democratic bench
nationally they're totally out of power
so we saw what happened there you know I
just can't believe it hopefully it
doesn't swing that far to the left Ben
got a run thanks so much